all of you here you're so young I'm
jealous
you're so young you've got to have a y
at some point because it's not gonna be
how much money you can gather it's not
gonna be how many toys cars houses at
some point it's gonna be a why'd I just
heard a why I had to take care of my
mother I just wanted to make $2,500 a
month so that I could give that to my
mother I've heard that but then it comes
back to you get to that some of you in
this room are gonna be so special but
it's not because of what you made it's
how many people you've helped your why
you gotta come up with what is my wife
when I make it big not if I make it big
I hurt you I hope you heard me
when I make it big what is my why what
do I want to be doing with my life you
know what write it down
put it on your bathroom mirror look to
that when I make it what do I want to be
about how do I want to be perceived just
a gatherer or maybe a gatherer or people
how many people can I help
don't you ever be embarrassed about
taking what you've been given what God
has given you and taking that thing to
another level because that's what you're
supposed to do